هذه مدرسه عمرو بن العاص التي كانت تؤوي
الاف النازحين وهي المدرسه الاخيره في
منطقه ابو اسكندر حيث بالامس دخلتها
الدبابات الاسرائيليه واعتقلت الرجال
والشبان والان المدرسه مخليه تماما
بالكامل كما تشاهدونها يعني هنا مزيدا من
الدمار كما تشاهدون في منطقه ابو
اسكندر حيث كانت الدبابات الاسرائيليه
تهرس كل شيء في طريقها هذه اثار سياره
اصبحت اثر بعد
عين
يعني احراق هذه السيارات بشكل متعمد كما
تشاهدون من قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قبل
انسحابها بدقائق عمل علينا طوقه ام تقريبا
من الساعه 4 الصبح اطلاق نار كتيف وعلى
جميع الدور اللي بتحرك قتلوا استشهد اللي
هو اللي بعبي مايه للحاره ابو عرب قتلوه
من دار ابو عبيد ودخلوا بالدبابات هنا
جربوه ما خلوش اي حاجه حياه لا ما لا شرف
اي حد تحرك حتى بده يجيب شربه مي كان قتل
على السريع ما ممنو حد يتحرك ماجو حد يبص
من البلكونه زي ما انت شايف كل هذا الدور
دمار ما خوش حاجهي منفس للحياه على سبه
رحلنا من المكان فضل لينا مدوين في البيوت
ما طلعنا من بيوتنا وهينا قاعدين في ببيوت
12 ساعه ونص قعد طيب كيف تبرت حالكم داخل
البيوت والله ضلينا في الجو تقريبا من
الساعه عه الصبح للساعه خسه المغرب لما
طلعوا قدرنا ن طبخنا لانه كله عايش
بدي انين ما عندي
انين
بموت يعني هنا المواطنون في حي الشيخ
رضوان وجدوا نقطه واحده لتعبئه المياه
منها بعد ان انسحبت الدبابات الاسرائيليه
من هذا المكان كما ما تشاهدون هنا يضون
بالالاف ليزيدوا المياه ولا تزال ايضا
الدبابات الاسرائيليه قريبه منه لكن لا
مناص لهم بعد حصار استمر ساعات داخل
منازلهم هنا يحاول الاهالي كما
تشاهدون البحث عن المياه لاي لاي غرض سواء
للشرب او للحياه
اليوميه هؤلاء المواطنون يبحثون عن ماء
كما تشاهدون في حي الشيخ رضوان في منطقه
ابو سكن
حيث ان قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه انسحبت
من هذا المكان كانت تتواجد هنا الدبابات
الاسرائيليه كما تشاهدون اثارها انسحبت
وتموضع في محيط مسجد التقوى ومحيط مسجد
ومحيط بركه الشيخ رضوان هناك تراجع قليل
في هذا الحي بعد بعد اشتبكات ضاريه مع
المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ايضا ارتكبت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي دمارا واسعا في هذه في هذه
المنطقه بعد انسحابها منها وكان هناك
العديد من الشهدا حتى ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي انسحبت من هذا الحي وخلفت
بعدها مجزره في منزلي عائله حجه وعائله
السويسي